oh my god they just released the new
trailer for Star Wars The Force awakens
it's amazing if you haven't seen it
click the link below watch it then come
back here for a full analysis and
reaction I'm Mark David Christensen this
I think is gonna be so good that we will
forget about all the prequels I mean all
three they won't exist can you imagine a
better outcome for this movie
this is hashtag news there's a huge
event today called Star Wars Celebration
JJ Abrams promised that there would be a
return to practical effects for this
movie bb-8 is a practical robot he was
on the stage rolling around but the
biggest reveal was the new trailer this
is the analysis of the trailer you were
looking for no pan across what I can
assume is tad a Wiens desert and what is
there a giant crash Star Destroyer which
looks like a relic at this point this is
way beyond the time period of Return of
the Jedi that's an artifact down then
there's Darth Vader's melted helmet
learn is that is that in ruins on Endor
is that on somebody's shelf are there
collectors in the Star Wars universe
like their Star Wars collectors and ours
then in fire light we have r2d2 being
petted by a robot hand oh we all know
who that robot hand is Luke Skywalker
why are you petting him I don't know
maybe he's consoling him maybe c-3po
something happened to him he's sad - the
robot hand Luke Skywalker was not in the
trailer except he does give voice over
talking about how he has the force his
father had the force and his sister has
the force what does that mean is Leia
gonna use the Force and then all the
action picks up in the trailer the
x-wings over the lake the controversial
lightsaber three blades reinf in in that
sucker ball droid running away from
danger then were startled by SIF popping
up with his red lightsaber which I can
only assume Adam driver do we get to see
the new design of the stormtroopers
they look great cuz they look like the
original concept art for Star Wars yes
JJ Abrams you went with the
concept art I could kiss you JJ Abrams's
now I will kiss you I will I'll kiss you
until you go rob because this Star Wars
is going to be amazing then John boyega
aka Finn removes his stormtrooper helmet
this is one of the most controversial
moments for Star Wars fans because in
the prequels it's been established that
stormtroopers are clones of Jango Fett
how can he be a stormtrooper if he's not
a clone then we get our first glimpse of
the chrome stormtrooper played by
Gwendoline Christie from Game of Thrones
then what is the cherry on top of this
trailer we're all holy where is home I
don't remember Han Solo talking about a
home I'm pumped for this movie I'm
assuming you're pumped I definitely know
this guy's pumped absolutely Star Wars
Episode 7 the force awakens you have
awoken my geek boner that's it for this
edition of hashtag news if you like this
video hit like down below and leave a
comment telling us what your favorite
moment was from the trailer and
subscribe to new media rockstars to say
update on the latest pop culture news
from Star Wars Game of Thrones and feel
Hilary Clinton running for president
stuff like that
that's adds as important I'm mark David
Christensen and may the force be with
you
that's from Star Trek oh crap